[Music]
i would date someone with a 20-year age
difference strongly agree strongly
disagree answer in the comments below
and suggest a prompt on our kickstarter
we've never been married yet we want to
get married it's like five year plan
get down right now
if you had to rank yourself against
others based on a specific trait
what would it say about how you see them
and how they see you to find out we
brought together five couples to rank
each other based on their assumed age
gap
then we rearrange them based on their
actual age gap this is ranking
say how long we've been together right
oh yeah should we go down the line yeah
sure yeah yeah we're about to hit a year
two days yeah that's two that's two way
a year or longer two years we've been
together for
four months yeah yeah
we got together i think it was in march
yeah march of this year no this last
year this last year so almost a year
we're almost here together so we met on
tinder we have been together for six
months six seven months yeah wanna talk
about work i'm unemployed i'm going to
nursing school
walking in and seeing all of the couples
here like i felt like i was for sure the
oldest person i work at a ninja warrior
gym she came interested in uh learning
like how to do obstacles our energies
really matched each other that's so cute
we're musicians okay
cool together i love that together and
separate so i'm a dog groomer and i am
going to school right now i uh graduated
school last year i've got my real estate
license my personal training certificate
just kind of yeah figuring it all out
what were you guys doing when covid
broke out i was in school still in
college i graduated during
the
pandemic what
did i expose something
but everyone can be in college like my
mom is in college that's what i'm saying
i'm like
i was in school who lives with their
parents or do you live on your own
i have my own apartment but she's always
there so i'm always there so i live with
my parents but if i were to move in with
her i would have to pay rent and i don't
pay rent for my parents
you got a good move right there we live
together we also live together at my
grandparents house for grandpa i live
with my grandma and my mom i live with
our roommate yeah and but i'm also
always with him so raise your hand if
you think zach is older
zach are you older i am you are oh
zach and michaela felt like they kind of
look like they go to school together
they kind of look around the same age
too raise your hand if you think mia is
older
oh she's older
it was so hard because she rolled in
with head to toe like beanie and
accessories and tattoos which eliminates
i was looking for like some skin aging
thank you by the way
wait who wears the hat i was the only
one oh okay
your face were like
we're kind of the same size so i was
just like comparing that as well like
they seem pretty similar like their
experiences and how they communicate
with each other um if you think i'm
older raise your hand
i'm not older
well i mean if you think i'm older raise
your hand
[Laughter]
have we been married before are we
thinking oh have you been married before
i have not been
married i do want to get married
i've never been married yet um we want
to get married like is it it's like five
year plan
like asap
but you know
okay
get down right now
i set it all up
i haven't thought about mirrored
seriously
until i met matrix
why couldn't you say that too he's
saying all the right things i feel like
this is such a loaded question yes i
want to get married i want to get
married as well i haven't been married
he hasn't either it's not a concept that
i'm opposed to
i feel like matrix and john i just me
and i'm always wrong so
i feel like you might be on the lower
end of the spectrum
i feel like you guys have a big age gap
that's kind of rude
everybody looks great i was thinking
that too i was like us two like top two
so i think matrix and john move down one
where do you think what do you think of
them
right here i also have another question
so like when you're with your friends or
family like what do they think about
your relationship yeah that's a good one
first i actually lied about his age and
then i lied again and then i told like
my mom that his actual age and i was
like uh-huh okay like i knew it so they
should stay there
yeah
and how about you guys my friends and
family were like
why oh
okay rude so my friends when they found
out at first they were like same thing
as her why
like they were shocked they did see why
y'all there's a lot of drama oh
but my mom
she supports me like my friend she was
kind of like kind of worried at first i
was like just just meet him and then
you'll see our relationship and then
you're like you'll understand yeah i
think y'all should switch yeah
so tall i think the three pairs down
there they're like
good i feel like you guys should switch
i don't know
you have a baby face
i want to see your guys like you guys
like
okay
those are like twins i think oh thanks
that's weird
do you guys want to i think they have
really what if we do rock paper scissors
i mean i you like so far everyone else
is saying we should say you said you're
always wrong
that's true that is true all right maybe
we should believe in you this time mate
give me one give me one i want this
i think let's just keep it keep it keep
it good it feels nice
[Music]
with the smallest age gap
we have
one year with zach and michaela nice job
tiana
[Music]
what month we won july
oh come on wait what's this about you
october october july okay
so what is that two months and then
how do we do this
oh okay
yeah so i feel like it's technically
here
[Music]
oh really
okay
[Applause]
wait so how old are you guys i'm 20 how
old do you think she is
oh wait it's 16 years old
so 36 33 wow
[Music]
i thought she was younger too guys
and i thought she was older but them
like i thought you guys would yeah
that's what i was gonna say yours were
like why hers was like why
yeah not to get into it too much but i
feel like it's also a religious thing oh
yeah for sure because like i know that
our families are heavily religious so
they're like oh you guys need to be a
certain way if you're happy it doesn't
matter yeah no for sure sometimes i
forget he's like 31 right no we forget
too yeah it's like oh look at this and
then he's like i don't get it i was like
oh that's right
i show her your tick tock and she's like
um i don't i don't get it i'm like never
mind sometimes
age is nothing but a number okay
sometimes age doesn't necessarily define
maturity of course it needs to be legal
it's more about like the vibe and if you
have things in common you can make it
work it was crazy because there's so
many couples that you like look at and
you're like they don't really make sense
but everybody up here like they it
looked like they all meshed really well
together i always thought like oh my
gosh six years we're so far apart and
then seeing couples that were like 12
and 16. it definitely changed how i see
ourselves it's normal to have that
reaction
knowing the big gap that we have but it
does kind of hurt you know like wow you
know why but they get it after a while
[Music]
you